jamais de bon
il bougeait était alors jamel il est
vraiment
c'est là ça fait plaisir
toutes les requêtes cette interview
l'autre était pas mieux non à défendre
les invités oui c'est plus facile que
jamais les bras non ça ne m'intéresse
pas ah oui désolé
jamel est ici ce soir pour une double
actualité est d'abord le jamel comedy
club sur canal+
et puis le film indigènes et comme je
pense qu'on dit que les arabes sont
feignants c'est énorme ce que vous
faites en une année c'est à dire s'il y
travail d'arabe voilà du bon tour et là
alors jamais le comedy club très beau
titre d'abord très facile très simple on
doit à kader aoun pena bravo kader tiens
j'en profite pour remercier calaire
l'expliqué pour cette émission depuis
quatre ans voilà aussi à présent la
milliardaire
alors isabelle comedy club au titre
émission diffusée tous les samedis à 20h
sur canal+ à partir du 15 juillet une
émission dans laquelle vous donner leur
chance à de nouveaux comiques
spécialisée dans le stand-up exact c'est
comme le petit théâtre de bouvard mais
en en drôle quoi en plus funky on dira
la voilà maintenant les pompiers bouvard
ils veulent à tous puis tabassé sur
canal c'est bien cette chaîne canal
c'est disons que c'est une chaîne qui
permet de qui laisse la place
ah ouais non c'est sûr que moi
d'ailleurs je remercie canal+ pour plein
de trucs enfin non 1
là on a été les voir avec ce concept ils
ont dit oui tout de suite j'avoue que ça
fait plaisir d'être avec des gens comme
ça voilà moi c'est c'est une aventure
humaine formidable et merci le but de
cette émission m'a vous dire qu'elle est
basée sur le stand up un micro quatre
artistes par émission qui viennent faire
cinq minutes de discours moi c'est vrai
que c'est c'est kader qui m'a montré
cette forme scénique je connaissais pas
le stand-up avant qu'il va parle j'ai
découvert richard pryor eddie murphy
dave chappelle c'est des mecs qui qui
sont dans le plus simple appareil
ils arrivent ils ont un micro à la main
et il te racontent qu'ils ont fait la
veille c'est incroyable il donne
l'impression que c'est que tout le monde
peut le faire en fait c'est ça c'est
comme quand tu vois zinedine zidane dans
une surface de réparation tu as
l'impression que tout le monde peut
faire la roulette
1 tu pourrais pas c'est plus une prise
de parole en fait que des pitreries quoi
c'est vraiment un discours quoi c'est
une étude sociologique cette émission
ouais tu vas voir on va regarder à quoi
ça ressemble c'est mieux 1 2 3
mallié